summer temperatures can exceed 40
degrees Celsius here in the karada in
the Kurdistan Region of Iraq
that's why biologist Hanna raza and her
colleague kir'shara like to get an early
start they're looking for traces of the
biggest predator here
a leopard that's considered the spirit
of the karada the local it's a flagship
species so it's very important it's on
its a top predator so it's on top of the
food chain the Persian leopard is
virtually invisible people who live here
in the mountains of karada know of the
leopard but very few have ever seen it
even Hanna raza who has been working and
doing research here for years now has
never encountered a leopard in the wild
that's why they used camera traps so the
sno-isle goat would get a lot of
pictures of them on our camera traps
which is a good indicator of the prey
availability for the persian leopard
this is one of the reasons why we get a
Persian leopard actually it seems this
morning we got a lot of pictures of
mammals different mammal species and
also a lot of birds we have the wild
goat we have the gray wolf jackhole fox
wild cats the Asiatic wild cats as well
the leopards have to compete with wolves
for their prey and occasionally other
leopards but Persian leopards have
become very rare in these mountains so
this leopard is their first photographic
record of the Persian leopard for Iraq
that we had and this through this we
just rediscover the Persian leopard in
2011 this one is a new individual that
we discovered in Canada in 2017 and this
way we know for sure that we have three
adult leopards living and roaming these
mountains
worldwide the population of Persian
leopards is estimated at less than 1300
the graceful yet ferocious big cat is
listed as endangered the
conservationists climb the steep rocky
terrain as often as possible they
haven't given up hope of spotting a
leopard on one of the other cliffs this
is its main hunting ground this is the
typical habitat for the leopards the
Persian leopard normally prefers oak
forests on rocky area so what they do is
when they hunt they normally sit on a
tree or under a tree and looking out and
overlooking what is going on there and
then when was they located prey they
just jumped down the mountain it's
easier for them because they're so
powerful and they jump so high as well
and once they are lucky together prey
then they drag it chew it onto a tree
and then that's where they eat it the
fate of the Persian leopard is dependent
on its habitat for decades of war
violence and human migration in Iraq
have left their mark on both people and
animals here the strength of the
leopards could be compared to the
strength of human beings especially
Kurds who withstood a lot of conflicts
and unrest in our region my family is a
Peshmerga family peshmerga's freedom
fighters those who fought against our
mass and so I was born in the mountains
while my parents were actually fighting
against a regime and my connection with
nature and the mountains goes that long
and I felt that as I grew up that my
parents fought for the mountains but now
there's nothing to see on the mountains
so I am striving to see wildlife back
again on the mountains like if you see
this mountain without animals and
there's no point of them
for years now hanna raza has been
negotiating with iraqi authorities to
establish a protected area in Qaradawi
her efforts seem to have paid off 2300
hectares of mountainous terrain are to
be designated and nature reserve for the
leopards the locals have to be convinced
as well years of unrest have forced
people to leave so there aren't many
left and the younger generation often
looked for jobs in the big cities but at
her Muhammad's Ali stayed for me the
leopard is a kind of natural heritage
I'd like to see more of them in these
mountains the new Nature Reserve is also
meant to attract tourists a much-needed
source of income a tourist Lodge is
currently being built with the support
of the International Union for
Conservation of Nature I understand that
a lot of people wouldn't expect that
this you know Iraq is for vacation and
for having fun but actually I can
promise that this region is very safe
but the first visitors are not the
guests they were hoping for oil reserves
are believed to be situated along the
border of the protected area even though
the oil company is considering ways to
support the reserve drilling would
nevertheless be inevitable after half an
hour the unwelcome visitors leave my
personal thinking is that oil and oil
exploration is one of the biggest
negative impacts on the environment and
no matter how much they try they would
still live a big footprint on the
environment the isolation of the
mountains in the Kurdistan region is the
best protection for Iraq's leopards only
if the area is left untouched says Hanna
raza does the spirit of the karada have
a chance
my vision for this future and especially
the conservation of wildlife
particularly is to have a network of
protected areas established for our
region to have more prosperity and to
have more peace for the local people in
local communities that live around them
and also for the wildlife
[Music]
you